hi everyone we have a sponsor today yes
it's what today's video is sponsored by
North Vee PN so did you know if you
don't have special protection on your
phone or a laptop when you're surfing in
public places people like hackers can
look into your [ __ ] and look into your
server and your IP and your HTTP P colon
slash slash they can do all that and see
what the hell you're doing so you need
to protect yourself because you don't
want these weird hackers coming in yeah
if you want to look at titties you gotta
pay mm-hmm have you ever had this
problem when you're travelling and for
some reason your favourite website is
blocked yes well guess what if you use
this you can actually access all of
these other websites that is not allowed
in North Korea nor VPN is super easy to
use you don't have to be a genius you
could be like me all dumb but just press
the button and it goes in a protects
your phone and your computers and it
just goes like that that's easy
yep raising are you trying to buy
Christmas gifts online yeah always
well you better watch out because
there's hackers out there that are
stealing information and who knows what
they're buying so it's gonna protect
yourself from hackers or if you don't to
leak your information out and your web
traffic history out you can get this and
I'll protect you
because the last thing I want is a huge
bill from someone who bought a kayak so
if you want to get north VPN go to north
VPN comm /jk news use the code JK knees
in to get 75% off of three year plan
plus if you get this right now you get
the whole month for read but you got now
go now link is in the description box
below
yeah shout out to North VPN for
sponsoring this video thank you very
much goodbye my family presents but
don't look at my website history
[Music]
in mobile finger news Oh like this yes
I'm mobile or mobile I see my vile
mobile I borrow your mobile mobile no I
just like sick [ __ ] can I just say like
me being really dumb like quick you know
you know like the thing that the Pope
drives and that the peop e mo bi le E
oil the Pope mobile mobile the
automobile what actually popemobile
popemobile really tip doctor correct
somebody oh yeah
that's time do you miss a whole episode
of me [ __ ] up like every other
full-blown meltdown nice I learned
saying you okay inspirational submitted
by Joel Mallya is greater than the
American dream I don't know about that
ball right no actually your lines are
longer yeah for basics no they're
shorter they're shorter because it just
kills awful oh I see when the lines get
longer but it's open to whatever he
feels like it though that's the problem
a researcher has invented a creepy robot
finger that attaches to your phone what
way why so that you don't get the carpel
tells you carpal tunnels but don't you
guys I still stick your finger in the
robot or not that would be defeat the
[ __ ] purpose it's just like a piece of
paper dude okay can you control the
finger with your mind not with your mind
but with someone else's like phone if
they want to send you like a caress they
can use that phone just be a caress yeah
Wow what
that's crazy invention
yo we have you ever gone that [ __ ]
handshake where somebody actually just
like Wiggles their finger oh yeah do
that make you feel because it feels
weird like there's nothing wrong with
you but it feel someone told me that
that means that they're trying to like
Bucky or something yank those bracelets
in half that they're trying to do a
bunch of strange things - well mrs.
Richardson's in [ __ ] kindergarten was
weird then what she did you guys never
have that those little rubber bracelets
they were like tied together and they
were like if you break it then like it's
a black one yeah you break are you gonna
[ __ ] right yeah that's what they said
they were like if you break a bracelet
then you gotta [ __ ] and they were like
third graders like snap like it was
really weird and then they think [ __ ]
is like looking at each other for a long
time now it is in your 30s I look at
very all the time you like that yeah it
was good huh yeah so this was invented
by Japanese guy Japanese guy guys it
pokes a lot of girls on Facebook mhm
Norwegians he's a super poke some
Scandinavian [ __ ] and maybe
anywhere Norway or Switzerland
what would you are like really like
loving kind of people I love la France
Paris Oh French researcher has invented
this robot finger yeah valve so it's an
unsharp about so he's saying that his
ph.d subject is around touch in
communications and so he's saying that
when we talked to people and realized
like well touch people like well like
have like I would do that to get more
tips when I was a cocktail waitress easy
I would give my right up for that [ __ ]
dude do it to me yeah alright like you
had music and it's like oh sorry what is
that oh my electric yeah let me get did
you poo bar mum were you like oh
there's a trail tip waitresses if they
blew it big boob arm you dude yeah
straight up I'm leaving with no money in
my wallet dude they always sexually hold
on but they're completely gone I'll give
you my wallet
do we sexually harass my arm at the
booth yes Sam
I don't know that one a she is black
t-shirt you ever wonder your life and
they're like that's a cute shirt are you
gonna get a tip yeah I'm chucking my
wallet at you and then I'm like oh I'm
sorry I like being do with it just keep
everything that seemed to give me the
wallet back yes I see my receipts right
Jim all right yeah so his name is mark
this is what he looks like
yeah he wouldn't look like that yeah he
looks like someone that has some [ __ ]
like that yeah cool I really hazel or
something but anyway so this is a video
of him talking about his weird creepy
fingers mark Tessier calls it the mobile
limb you can get its commands from
someone on the other side of the phone
yeah hug your friend will tell it to oh
my god how many people transport late
the reaction tells us something about
who we are as humans and maybe with
refinement we can get more of a
connection to the machines around us
after all he says you might not throw a
device in the trash after two years if
you had that personal touch couldn't he
have studied something more useful yeah
could you have gotten a more boring
person to [ __ ] do that to move so
slow it's [ __ ] creepy
like wait this should slow got a PhD
Peter no so he's working on his PhD he's
a researcher at Telecom Paris tech
engineering school sounds like the
University of Phoenix for me yeah but
for France accepted into University of
Phoenix by the way is highly graduation
thank you
it's prestigious yeah it happened at the
age of 14 too by the way
oh yeah he's just saying how it's just
interesting that now cuz everyone finds
this really creepy the Mobe limb because
he did patent this mobile mobile in
thank you yeah so you say that it's just
interesting that because
it's attached to something that's not
human now all of a sudden like touch is
just creepy from a device but he agrees
well I don't know if he agrees all
saying like a lot of people find this
creepy but then when we do like you know
first human or human communication and
we're talking and touching that's not
creepy
we have [ __ ] robots is also creepy
yeah yeah well I mean okay
in the sense of Technology and touch
he's onto something cuz y'all know how
touch is like one of the live like love
languages yeah it's really important so
it's my love language is it I think he's
mine - that's why I don't hug people
because I don't want to give it away you
know all the time but otherwise I got to
protect my love touch is very important
to me so like I feel like he's on to
something but like the little thumb loop
the robot finger is like really and also
it's just one finger like nobody touches
you just one thing I know right
I miss you so much would you would you
rather have a hand a hand that's
connected to like squeeze you like let
me get a USB hand or something like it's
a USB handle that means the anger part
is gonna be ridiculous
Oh like if you say something bad and
officers like you I wish you would it'll
just be this all day my wife yeah I like
to me me to my wife all day long you're
right I miss you it's like we already do
that at home
oh we go around corners with each like
this to each other
that's our love language is ballbusting
slow-mo she just jump out of the court
it's good morning no but you have to
plug it in he's trying it's like hey
baby plug it in
I'll just be sitting there and I see
something like or my look and it's just
two hands alone like this corner it's
great do you you know on your phone it
lets you know help how much time you're
wasting now yeah yeah I [ __ ] hate
that thing dude that [ __ ] hurts my
feelings cuz there's a you could turn it
off yes in my face all the time he goes
three hours you were a loser today
that's what can I say like yo this is
for work I swear to God like hey it's
written as incidents for work I swear
the crazy thing is nobody else is
watching it so I had to lie to myself
yeah I don't see it on my phone I've
only seen it on Instagram it pops up on
my shoes well I was most manly most
mostly angry about I logged in I saw the
time and I was like a [ __ ] like I
logged out and two minutes later I went
to go check the time again it had gone
up a minute cuz I gonna inspect it and I
got even more mad wait what is this what
is this I told you how you allocate your
time on your phone if it's like on
social media [ __ ] if it's for work if
it's for other stuff like depending on
what apps you use on your phone yeah you
would an Instagram tells me I'm all
caught up I get pissed I'm like cuz you
know how it says now it's like you've
already looked at this [ __ ] and I'm like
yeah but anything else you didn't know
you're a loser
yeah exactly I'm like well I know but
don't tell me yes oh this French
researcher here he's saying that maybe
someday in the future that we'll have
like some sort of like really personal
connections with our devices or our
future robots Oh that'll get me up there
[ __ ] singularity [ __ ] you bro way
every two years if we had like a
personal connection okay that's weird I
thought that he was using this as a
means to make other people connect
better but now he's like to the devices
gross yeah yeah that's gross yeah if
you're if you're like little finger
robot thing like touch your wiener or
something it'd be hard to throw it away
after that cuz like yeah that's personal
that's real personal yeah if your phone
touches your dick do you know I feel
like I would throw it away pretty
quickly out of shame yeah well it's one
of the other it's like a hard cut thing
Scott who the other pair like Eve it or
throw it away
yeah that's creepy man
I feel about that we'll do y'all
remember like ten years ago when they
came out with those kissing machines
like what the it was like a Bluetooth
kissing machine remember I remember they
were like from Japan and like you could
like make out with you could let me see
that
oh yeah the [ __ ] one oh yeah come on
now that's a little different
oh that's just a human thing yeah yeah I
remember there you could buy [ __ ]
from people like you could download what
their bone job would feel like yeah the
poor little thing right no I didn't hear
about that sounds so that's incredible
you stick your dick in a machine right
yeah there's [ __ ] bars in Japan but I
guess like if you're a foreigner you
can't go to those bars you have to be a
Japanese native and they'll allow you in
and literally you're at a bar
who told me this but like you can go to
Japan and then you'll have a drink and
then somebody is sucking your dick
underneath the bar a person that's
[ __ ] awesome
no each says this [ __ ] when you're going
to the Tourism Board for Japan it's like
you've gone aboard and you can drink on
the bus kind of cool but it's like hey
you go and you sit in a bar and they
blow you it's like oh yeah I'm there I'm
going to this bar
you wouldn't care who it is you just
want one fits under the table then what
do you care yeah it could be whoever the
[ __ ] what if it's a dude then you're gay
that's a great way to find out like for
happy right yeah no no if you look under
the table after you're like wow that was
great I'm gonna table and it's a guy's
like hi and you're like oh what a great
way to find out I'm gay the stubble
threw me off a little bit I was like I
wasn't sure what that was
yeah I mean if it's a good blow it's a
good blow it's a good well thank you
how'd you do that one thing how much you
pay something like that cost a few
hundred bucks would blow job and ramen
oh it's you while getting a blow job why
don't I just heard your pants I just
thought like you're eating ramen up here
and it's like some person cause crawls
underneath and you're given a [ __ ]
you know could you even focus on it
could you eat I got my challenge my
buddy said that his wife gave him
permission to get a Japanese [ __ ]
Oh only in Japan well they were going to
Japan and she gave him the dose of the
calf yeah I wonder if he asked for it or
she was just like hey man it'd be really
chill if you got your dick soaked by
some chick or he was just like you can
experience Japan fully thing what if she
was trying to get out of her own like
she's like I want to enjoy the city I
don't want to suck any dick while I'm
out here you can get your dick so go
ahead bye good luck to him the [ __ ]
teeth in Japan are crazy doing oh my god
dude
the Japanese teeth are [ __ ] insane
dude like I don't know if they don't
give a [ __ ] about dental but that [ __ ]
looks like they chew on dynamite oh my
god oh my god it's like British teeth
the popular the worse worse oh my I
don't know what it is because when I was
in a Hawaii - I don't we thought in
Japan - but when I was in Hawaii there's
a lot of Japanese tourists
I see like 60 to 70% of the men the
teeth were a little crazy there's just
like sweet little Japanese girl on her
boat when we were doing like this
underwater scuba thing and then she
smiled and I would like a bamboo just
like very good she flashed neither of
them oh no it was like it was like green
and black and like dark around the peep
and it was just all impact I mean that
was a nightmare broad angry and then I
woke up and I little [ __ ] but it was
like crazy dude I couldn't stop talking
about in the mirror got mad at me she'll
stop talking about it I couldn't stop
thinking about it the whole time he was
over there and then when he came home I
was like did you do it he's like nah I
know that's [ __ ] genius yeah but
that's that's scary though cuz for a
dude he'd be like this a [ __ ] test oh
yeah it could be exactly he's in the
brothel he's like something feels weird
man
I'm gonna rock n roll today
sumimasen you are not hang on a second I
know what you're up to
yeah I just have the ramen today
see that's our wives just kidding our
have no blood like dudes just like next
year just getting them sucked and you're
just like soups good I come here for the
soup yeah really nice really nice just
in case you miss the whole entire brand
deal right in the beginning of the video
you can go ahead and click the link down
below and get 75% off for the first
three years of getting noir VPN and
guess what if you get it right now you
get an extra month for free
isn't that awesome just use the code JK
news at noir VPN dot-com /jk news
[Music]